Tristan has said before like I'm his
person I'm not saying I don't believe
him but I've heard this and of course
it's angered me before because I'm like
well if I am then why would you've
treated me this way and how many times
you know like it's this isn't like oh a
onetime thing and here we are like I I
love love and I am a hopeless romantic
but that's not going to change how I
feel and what happened for me you know
entering this new chapter in my life uh
it's always good to have a strong
support system people that believe in
you so I told M I appreciate her I
appreciate you as well yeah Tristan no
matter what like we're not a family of
like eye for an eye especially in times
of need like that's when you rally
together and I want to be good for the
lifetimes after this I want my karma
just to always be great